[Música]
en france 24 es hora de hablar de
economía por ello ya me acompaña en el
estudio mi compañera daniela blandón
daniela bienvenida vamos a empezar con
el pronunciamiento del presidente de
eeuu que arremetió contra el
neoliberalismo en su pronunciamiento en
la cumbre de las américas o la valentina
buenas noches pues dijo el presidente
que es momento de enterrar este sistema
que ha sido tan polémico en varios
países porque lo que hace es limitar la
intervención del estado en el ámbito
económico y en su lugar fomentar la
inversión privada job aiden propuso que
haya una asociación económica de eeuu
con los países de américa latina para
contrarrestar la influencia china y
aprovecho para decir que es hora de
actualizar lo que se conoce como trickle
down o economía del goteo que consiste
en reducir impuestos a las empresas y a
las clases altas para estimular la
inversión
[Música]
la economía de goteo no funciona cuando
invertimos en fortalecer a los
trabajadores y la clase media los pobres
tienen una escalera hacia arriba y los
que están en la cima lo hacen y así es
como podemos aumentar las oportunidades
y disminuir la inequidad persistente
daniela y la justicia francesa oa
resolver un pleito legal entre el grupo
casino y los indígenas del amazonas y
valentina pues en una audiencia
celebrada este jueves en un tribunal
francés un juez propuso primero una
mediación entre esta cadena de
supermercados francesa y un grupo de
indígenas que llegó hasta el lugar desde
brasil esto para evitar que lleguen
hasta un juicio y es que los grupos
amazónicos alegan que el grupo francés
dueño en colombia de almacenes éxito y
en brásil de palo de azúcar que son las
más grandes cadenas minoristas no
realizó un adecuado rastreo de su cadena
de suministro y que terminó vendiendo
carne de res vinculada a la
deforestación también a abusos de los
derechos humanos y a la invasión de
territorio indígena en la amazonía que
comparten estos dos países esta es la
primera vez valentina que una cadena de
supermercados francesa es llevada a los
tribunales por este motivo escuchemos a
uno de los distritos en la red del grupo
casino apoya la agricultura en brasil y
esos agricultores corrompen a los
caciques y líderes políticos indígenas
para crear haciendas de cereales a gran
escala les prometen grandes sumas de
dinero una vida fácil para ellos
escuelas privadas para sus hijos
entonces esta es una forma de corrupción
de familias enteras que viola una serie
de derechos colectivos dio las sondas
sus directos colectivos
daniela y el banco central europeo- a
subir sus tasas de interés por primera
vez en 11 años si huelen tiene para
ponerlo en términos muy sencillos esto
es lo que los analistas han llamado el
fin del dinero barato porque porque con
esta decisión que tomó el banco central
en su reunión de hoy de aumentar en 25
puntos básicos las tasas de interés en
julio lo que hace es tratar de
desincentivar el consumo y hacer que sea
más caro acceder al crédito para
finalmente frenar el fuerte ascenso de
los precios y es que hay países en los
que la inflación está en los niveles que
no se veían hace años y hasta décadas
escuchemos por ejemplo que dice la gente
en bélgica que es uno de los países que
más ha subido en inflación va un 10%
aproximadamente en el último año como
que tú tomo obviamente todo está
subiendo y no se puede hacer nada contra
eso cuando voy a hacer mis compras de
abarrotes compro - compro cosas más
baratas compro marcas de supermercado
productos de bajo costo
cuando se trata de hacer las compras en
un supermercado para mis necesidades
diarias no puedo permitirme obtener todo
lo que compraría antes es más una
cuestión de elegir prioridades
el aumento de precios es enorme aunque
sólo sea el combustible para mí como
taxista estoy luchando porque ahora pago
el doble del precio es un aumento
francamente increíble
daniela y vamos a finalizar con los
indicadores económicos de esta jornada
nos valentín a la palabra de la semana
inflación o el sweater cerró con
notables pérdidas como antesala
pesimista de un dato de inflación a mayo
que se conocerá este viernes américa
latina también término negativa después
de conocerse datos de inflación en el
último año los precios en méxico han
subido casi 8% y en brasilia rompieron
la barrera del 11 por ciento europa hizo
lo propio grandes pérdidas en las bolsas
después de los anuncios del banco
central europeo de los que ya hablamos
daniela a usted muchas gracias por esta
ampliación económica ya continuamos aquí
en directo américa con